first of all when you talk about your
beginnings right you had some crazy
[ __ ] jobs last time you were here
you told me you sold uh vacuum cleaners
right no the finest thing was fire
extinguishers [ __ ] door-to-door
were you were you good at it jb be
honest were you good at selling a fire
extinguisher door-to-door [ __ ] yeah you
work do me a [ __ ] great pretend i'm a
housewife all right you knock on the
door i guess what were your hours when
you would sell fire extinguishers i made
my own [ __ ] hours did you yeah that's
now people don't realize this but there
are times of the day where your house is
primed to catch on fire [ __ ] is
that right [ __ ] yeah what would those
times be after like uh after three
o'clock when the kids get home right
when the kids get home [ __ ] get crazy
and you got to start preparing dinner
and that kind of [ __ ] that's when your
house might burn the [ __ ] down because
there's too much [ __ ] going on you can't
keep up with the [ __ ] kids grandpa's
over there making oodles of noodles and
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] he's doing but
when is the best time to sell the fire
extinguisher i would think when the
house is calm and empty no [ __ ] that no
you want chaos right you want [ __ ] going
on see when you when someone you knock
on someone's door and you [ __ ]
selling fire extinguishers you want what
you got to do but i would do it too
people think it was it was jehovah
witness at first or or something like
that no they do they're different yeah
they're [ __ ] different right you know
you open that goddamn door and i say
hello hello ma'am yeah you know uh
and then the first thing i do is put my
foot into the threshold oh is that true
you always did they tell you that or you
just knew to do it you said it's an all
over tv shows they all did that andy
griffith show
matlock you would do that and you
weren't afraid they'd close the door on
your phone tv land [ __ ] you know you
open the door you put your [ __ ] you
put your plants your foot right in the
[ __ ] threshold yeah so they can't
close the [ __ ] door really they try
to slam it down your [ __ ] face yeah
right and you lean over like like 30 35
degrees over to look into the house and
see what the [ __ ] is going on in there
right right you might see a grandpa in a
[ __ ] wheelchair some [ __ ] like that
could you go to like a white
neighborhood and stuff fire fire
extinguishers were they afraid that a
black guy was at the door [ __ ] matter
really you hold that fire extinguisher
in your [ __ ] hand oh did you bring it
with you you better you better have
something in your [ __ ] hand yeah you
got to have something in your [ __ ]
hand you got a whole little kit all
right right and you got a little pin a
little a little fire a little fire pin
on your [ __ ] lapel yeah you know and
you lean over to see what the [ __ ] is
going on in there you see [ __ ] kids
running around you see you see some food
on the stove and [ __ ] and you lean back
you tell her say uh i see you have kids
you know i see have a grandpa in a
wheelchair or something [ __ ] like that
and you say uh are you protected by
having yourself a fire extinguisher and
she'll say [ __ ] no see and they'll
say you know we have a really great
great uh uh program going on here i can
get you three or four uh great fire
extinguishers for every [ __ ] room and
these just came in varieties one of
those different kind of fires it's all
different kind of [ __ ] box it's like
a grease fire that's a greased [ __ ]
fire there's one for the garage you
should have one in every [ __ ] room
what was your best day like would you
like could you sell ten to one family or
or would they just buy one some if you
get a big-ass house you can sell
four or five of them bad boys if they
don't have any at all nobody sells door
to door anymore that's in lost time i
never saw a fire extinguisher
all right now if a [ __ ] was
really smart he would combine two or
three different things together like
imagine like
how long did you do it for about a year
yeah i might do that less than a year
really i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] them and
lost that job how'd you lose it
almost burned somebody's [ __ ] house
down i told you the story you started
the fire
yeah you got to set a sample fire right
you know what i mean and here's the
funny [ __ ] here's the [ __ ] they teach
you how to do they teach you how to
listen but they teach you to have
selective hearing so and basically when
they ask you questions
something you got to uh uh answer and
something you got to ignore like when
you said that when i set that little pan
up on your table and tear paper up and
put a little lighter fluid in that
[ __ ] pan and i go to
i can't imagine letting you in my house
with [ __ ] papers and lighter fluid
pull that [ __ ] massive book out and
you say
are you gonna start a fire in my house
you ignore the [ __ ] out
them anyway
you like of
[Music]